we really depend on adrenalin throughout
the day we pump ourselves up we drink
too much caffeine we over schedule
ourselves wait till the last minute to
get things done and we depend on it you
know many people want to feel that
urgency in order to actually accomplish
something however what happens when we
live that kind of adrenaline filled
lifestyle is that we're exhausting our
system so we know that short-term stress
can be great it can really help you get
through a deadline and mobilize you
however if you depend on that day after
day after day you'll find that your body
becomes worn out your immune system is
impacted and even your mind your
attention in your memory are impaired
through that long-term chronic stress on
the other hand if you and train your
train yourself to be more calm rather
than always in high adrenaline mode you
will be saving your energy much more not
to say that you shouldn't have that
intensity and excitement in your life
and spend a lot of energy but you should
really be saving your energy and
spending it when you want to for the big
major projects in your life the big
events so consider this is about energy
conserving your energy and this is where
calmness comes in and it's something
that's not very much valued in American
society in particular we value intensity
at all times whether we're at work or
whether we're at play one of the most
effective ways to bring calm into your
nervous system is through breathing
breathing exercises in one very
interesting research study scientists
looked at the link between emotions and
breath they looked in particular at
whether emotions will change your
breathing pattern so they had
participants come in and they told them
to elicit these emotions within
themselves and the scientists then
measured how the participants were
breathing how deeply how long etc and
what they found was that lo and behold
each of the emotions that was elicited
was linked to a different unique pattern
of breath
the more interesting part of the study
was the second part of the study other
participants were brought in and were
simply given the breathing the breathing
techniques that corresponded to the
emotions witnessed in the first part of
the study and what they found was that
when they asked those participants how
they felt the participant
said that they felt the emotion that
corresponded to the breathing pattern
what this shows is that our breath can
significantly change the state of our
mind so usually if we're in a very
high-stress moment it's very difficult
to talk ourselves out of it it's even
less helpful if someone else is hey calm
down it's just very challenging to
change your mind with your own mind your
thoughts with your own thoughts however
if you if you calm your nervous system
which is what we do with the breath then
your mind can start to calm down as well
one breathing exercise that's very
effective requires you to just take your
right hand and put the index and middle
finger of that right hand right between
your eyebrows and then you just want to
place your thumb on your right nostril
and your ring finger on your left
nostril and you want to take a deep
breath in here you can go ahead and
close your eyes and then close the right
nostril with your thumb and exhale on
the left side and then inhale on the
left side deep breath in and then
closing that left nostril exhale on the
right side so you're alternating
nostrils breathe in on the right side
again close the right nostril and
breathe out on the left and then breathe
in on the left deep breath switch and
breathe out on the right and then
continue in this way switching after
each inhale taking long deep and slow
breaths you can do this for about five
minutes and when you're ready you can
open your eyes and you'll see a shift in
the state of your mind
you